just randomly while I'm sitting across
from you I realized I wanted to ask you
this
um I loved rings of power on Prime video
uh which is you know Lord of the Rings
um and I'm just curious if you got to
watch any of it and what your thoughts
were yeah I I I've absolutely watched it
and uh you know it really once you know
you get through the
uh understanding the rules of it of it
and and and and actually how loyal to
the trilogy and the the feel of the
trilogy
um music by Howard Shore for the opening
sequence Etc you know it's it's um
it actually I found it incredibly
engaging and I I really really enjoyed
watching it and and also
um I I because I'd done an audio book
recording of of The Lord of the Rings
and read the appendices and I had to
read them out loud I thought it was
quite clued up about about that
particular you know where it was going
to go which was which was which was
great and it was really helpful because
I'm going to be don't tell anybody but
reading this silmarillion as well so
um
uh you heard this here first
um so yeah no so I really enjoyed it
very much so uh first of all thanks for
sharing and second of all for anyone who
has not watched uh rings of power we're
talking about Endor but rings of power
is also pretty good